utilisateurs
de la patrie le jour de gloire et arrivé
contre nous de
la mes chers camarades dans ces
conditions à prouver que nous ne sommes
que nous ne sommes ni des destructeurs
ni des déstabilisateurs ni de dénigreur
mais que nous autres nationalistes nous
sommes pour la France de demain nous
sommes les constructeurs nous sommes les
réformateurs nous serons les
rassembleurs qu'attendent les forces
vives dans ce pays réel
gardons-nous en effet de ce mirage
facile qui consiste à croire qu'en
balayant quelques nuisances en fermant
quelques officines et en expulsant
quelques indésirables on aura rendu la
France aux français puisque tel est le
propos sur la base duquel nous nous
réunissons aujourd'hui il me semble
que si de mécontentement catégoriel ont
pour unique objectif de
raviver des
désirs strictement matériels dans une
période de pénurie ces mécontentement
n'ont pas de légitimité si maintenant
d'une
protestation contre des réformes
médiocres contre une politique
finalement
anesthésiante
aboutissent à une contestation du
système politique dans lequel nous
vivons et bien
ces manifestations prennent un sens
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'il est très important de
politiser
l'aimer contentement catégoriels et de
leur donner un contenu politique
[Applaudissements]
nous y sommes nous y participons en tant
que syndicat étudiant mais aussi nous
voulons aller au-delà des revendications
purement syndicales pour le développer
des thèmes politiques dans l'université
on veut faire croire que les militants
du lieu de sont tous en tous le crâne
rasé qui se balade en bottes et blousons
de cuir je crois pas en avoir vu
beaucoup actuellement le besoin de cuir
qu'on nous reproche et
très efficace pour parer les coûts et
croyez moi on nous accuse peut-être
d'attaquer et de taper sur tout le monde
mais je crois qu'on prend beaucoup de
couples les jeunes qui viennent à
diriger nous leur disons tout de suite
très clairement nous sommes
nationalistes ils ont une plaquette qui
lisent ils sont d'accord ou non s'ils
sont nazis ils s'en vont s'ils sont
nationalistes il reste on les retrouve
participant aux manifestations par en
train de faire le coup de poing dans les
manifestations ils viennent s'exprimer
dans la rue
c'est un des seul endroit où c'est le
droit de s'exprimer aujourd'hui le
nationaliste et je ne s'exprimer dans la
rue nous croyons dans un homme qui se
dépasse sans cesse par le combat par la
lutte par l'action et la croix celtique
et le symbole de cet homme qui sans
cesse cherche à se dépasser lui-même et
non pas à rester légal de son voisin
[Musique]
vous êtes tous rasé vous avez tous les
jours violents
[Musique]
il y a souvent des gens qui nous
attaquent
[Musique]